in the calibers own region of the
Philippines the tyrell volcano has
turned the landscape monochrome whole
villages are blanketed in stick layers
of volcanic ash and formerly lush
plantations have been left
unrecognizable jak Imperial has found
pineapple for 17 years he says he's
never seen such devastation the
pineapples were all covered by thick mud
we can't use them anymore Imperial has a
small stool at a local market and makes
a living by selling pineapples to
tourists not this year almost all his
crops are ruined even if we were able to
harvest some pineapples for sale if
customers are scared to come because of
the eruption the pineapples will just
end up rotting an estimated 3,000
hectares of land has been affected by
ash fall in Colaba zone and the
agricultural damage has already exceeded
10 million euros experts say that in the
long term the volcanic ash will help
replenish the soil making it more
fertile in the future but before that
farmers like Jack Imperial will have to
survive the huge losses caused by
destroyed crops authoritative warning
that a massive eruption could happen at
any time the volcano is about 70
kilometres south of the capital Manila
in the middle of a lake it started to
expel ash on Sunday well rescue teams
have been working around the clock to
get people to safety DWS Anna Santos has
joined one of the admissions
clouds of ash covered this road in
Batangas region but still the rescuers
press on determined to drive those
trapped in this volcanic danger zone to
safety we are doing rescue operations to
evacuate people to higher ground we've
rescued a couple of people already this
morning we're moving to another town to
rescue more the tar tho Cano has been
billowing smoke into ash since its
eruption on Sunday it lies in the middle
of a lake just over 60 kilometres south
of the Philippine capital Manila
although these Filipinos don't live on
the volcanic island they are still in
danger ash fall and the likelihood of
more eruptions are making evacuations
here mandatory others like Claire and
her sisters are choosing to get out
while they can we decided to evacuate
today because we heard that things may
get worse with the volcano the safest
thing to do is to leave some areas are
too difficult to reach by truck
so these rescuers use motorbikes to
collect the locals it doesn't matter how
they find them they simply know they
have to get people out of this region as
quickly as possible